and viewers have been reaching out to
Channel A concerned with the state's
child support payment system apparently
not working properly so it turns out
that the issue is actually bigger than a
lot of people expected
Christian casares has been working to
get you answers
it's like I have you know no child
support coming in since the beginning of
October Robin Atkin says money has been
tight because the Nevada child support
system is not working my registration
fees for DMV that's a big chunk rent is
obviously a big chunk
um you know all the basics for my
daughter picture day and all the fun
school activities Halloween is affected
by that according to the state's website
the Division of Welfare and Supportive
Services is implementing a new Nevada
Child Support Enforcement automated
system called Envy kids a modern effort
to adapt to changing business needs
we've added a self-service portal so you
don't have to come into the office for a
handful of tasks that you used to have
to come to an office for Julie belderson
with the State Department of Health and
Human Services says the system
previously used needed an update since
its launch in October she says there
have been some outages but repairs are
in process the thing that's important to
remember about our child support
enforcement program is that it's a
collaborative partnership between the
county level District Attorney's offices
and the state level Child Support
Enforcement program so we do these
things together for now Atkins says she
will rely on her savings which won't get
her far as inflation and gas prices will
keep her and her young daughter limited
until she can get the proper assistance
I understand that there's a lot of other
families affected by this
and I'm sure you know I'm not the only
one dealing with us it's just very
frustrating right now